gbtc
discount hit a record minus 26.5
as many people know grayscale's bitcoin
trust one of the most popular bitcoin
products the largest bitcoin product in
the world especially for hedge funds and
large institutional investors
they had a premium for years which meant
that the nav the actual amount of
bitcoin that was in the fund the stock
was trading at a higher price so you
could basically buy the grayscale shares
in the private market and then when it
became liquid you would be able to
arbitrage that with what the stock
traded at that is called the gbtc
premium arbitrage trade literally there
was billions of dollars put into this
trade but as you can see here in this
chart starting in the beginning of 2021
that premium flipped to a discount at
first it was a small discount but it has
gotten bigger and bigger and bigger gbtc
hit a record 26.5 discount meaning that
the stock trades 26 and a half percent
lower than the actual bitcoin that is in
the fund now gbtc has about 27 billion
dollars or so it's down 17
in 2022. why exactly has that discount
increase well there's been a recent sell
off in bitcoin which contributed to a
larger discount as well of course
bitcoins down 37 percent from its
all-time high in november gbtc doesn't
allow for share redemptions like in etfs
and of course there's also been etf
launches in canada and other places
around the world now the derivatives
backed btc etfs launched in the united
states also so ultimately what people
were doing is they were buying in the
private market they were then waiting
six months in one day for it to become
liquid traded then they would arbitrage
the premium when it flipped to a
discount that no longer was available
and so ultimately what ends up happening
here is that people who are holding gbtc
they have a couple of options they can
sell out the discount 26.5 less than the
bitcoin price uh or the bitcoin amount
in the fund or they can hold and wait
grayscale is actively working they're
trying to convert this trust into an etf
now there's a lot of people who want
them to issue some sort of uh redemption
functionality uh or allow that there's
other people who say look just convert
it to an etf but the big hurdle to
converting gbtc into an etf is the
regulators the sec they have not
approved a spot bitcoin etf yet they
only have that derivative-based on and
so ultimately what we are watching is a
waiting game how long will it take for
the sec and other regulators to actually
go ahead and approve a bitcoin etf in
the spot market then how long will it
take for them to approve grayscale to
convert the grayscale bitcoin trust gbtc
into an etf once that happens you would
expect to see a return to nav almost
immediately and of course anyone who'd
holding the asset then that would be
positive for them we have a couple of
quotes first with the director of
research and cio at etf trends he said
there's still no way for bitcoin to ever
leave gbtc which means it should
continue to trade with a substantial
discount to reflect that illiquidity
grayscale i think has like three or
three and a half percent of all bitcoin
in circulation inside that fund then the
president of spectral markets gbtc keeps
breaking hearts as the discount widens
gbtc is basically a binary bet on a
physical etf at this point tempting but
tempting the way value traps can be
tempting so obviously he ain't so
excited
then we have james seyfried who
obviously has been on the podcast before
he broke down what would happen if it
was converted to a spot etf he said gbtc
is still trading at a massive discount
around 26.3 percent many think this
means a 26 return if the fund converts
to an etf but the return is actually
much bigger eliminating a 26.5 discount
would be analogous to a security
appreciating to 100 from
73. uh 73.50
which is a 36
return there's no guarantee this
discount will ever collapse or that the
discount couldn't get worse and these
scenarios excludes the risks and price
movements of bitcoin itself but gbtc is
essentially a levered bet on u.s spot
bitcoin etf approval at this point in
his opinion i tend to think that this is
a very very interesting opportunity
people who understand the risks and who
want to take that levered bet on a u.s
spot bitcoin etf we'll go ahead and
allocate capital here and also people
who don't want to do that will just go
buy bitcoin on the spot market what do
you guys think so my question is uh the
incentives that grayscale has to convert
this doesn't their fee like dramatically
get reduced if it turns to an etf like i
know they've said that they're going to
do it right and they
you have to take them at their word for
that but ultimately like the fees
dramatically decrease i believe if uh it
gets turned to an etf so they would be
incentivized to keep it in the structure
that it is today right so the grayscale
bitcoin trust i just looked this up i i
believe this is true is that grayscale's
uh annual management fee is two percent
on that fund which is high compared to
an etf for sure yeah the average equity
etf charge is just 0.53 percent so it's
about four times higher than the average
equity etf from a fee perspective but
ultimately what's worse than it being uh
fee compression which i think ultimately
everyone in this space believed was
going to happen
the worst thing is that if you're at
this massive discount you basically have
to shut off new capital inflows and so
that's what they've had to do they're
not taking more capital in and the
private placement and so if you're not
taking more capital and you can't grow
aum and so even if you are going to get
less
money on a per investor basis in terms
of the fee you charge
the more important thing is that you
continue to grow assets and especially
if you're the largest player if all of a
sudden you get caught you can't take new
assets in somebody else can you may
actually give up the number one spot if
somebody else is able to take in assets
you're not and you basically are caught
in this uh you know this discount so i
think that for them and for the investor
it's better when it gets converted
they've been very open with it look they
had their lawyers actually published a
thing saying hey you know there may be
legal action here for us to force the
regulator's hands etc etc uh i think
it's just
it's a weird situation for everyone uh
and until it gets converted to a spot
etf i think that we're just gonna
continue to see this if you go and you
buy gbtc today basically what you're
doing is you're buying uh 73 or so of
bitcoin or you're buying a hundred
dollars for bitcoin for 73 dollars the
question is just in the future if you go
to sell it will it be worth the hundred
dollars of bitcoin that you actually
bought will it be worth 73 or will it be
worth less right nobody knows where it's
gonna end up being but i think part of
what is so tempting about it is that uh
you're basically buying a hundred
dollars worth of bitcoin for 73 dollars
right so it is a discount uh and the
idea is that if you have a really really
long time horizon uh ultimately the
question comes down do i think that
they're going to be able to convert this
to the spot etf if so then it's
interesting if you don't think that's
gonna happen then you should stay away
from it now the other piece of the
analysis that people forget is you're
not just making a bet on only the
conversion because there's still price
exposure to bitcoin so if bitcoin goes
down in price that will affect gbtc if
bitcoin goes up in price that'll be a
tailwind for gbtc as well so there's the
discount plus the price exposure to
bitcoin so i think ultimately people who
are buying this right now in the most
basic sense they're making two things
that they say okay i believe i believe
that bitcoin will be a good bet over
some period of time that is my
investment horizon and i believe that
bitcoin uh the grayscale bitcoin trust
will either not have a bigger discount
or it will end up actually going back to
nav or close to nav right so like the
discount will actually become less or
eventually return back to nav so if you
believe bitcoin's a good bet and you
believe that uh it's gonna happen then
people would end up buying